in response to russia's invasion of
ukraine a number of russian banks no
longer have access to the swift
international payment system now that
could open an opportunity for china's
alternative cross-border inter-bank
payment system or sips as china is
russia's leading trade partner unveiled
in 2015 sips helped establish the yuan
as an international currency sipp's aim
is to allow banks to process
cross-border u1 transactions directly
now according to chinese official data
sips has some 1200 participants from
more than 100 countries and regions that
includes russian banks and chinese
subsidiaries of deutsche bank last year
sips processed transactions worth almost
13 trillion us dollars now chinese media
says that was a 75
increase from the previous year
currently sips though still relies on
swift for international communication
russia's financial ties with china could
increase cut off from all trade partners
moscow is forced to reorganize much of
its economy and trade with a focus on
beijing
it's been a month since the winter
olympics opened in beijing with
fireworks and chinese president xi
jinping waving proudly from the stands
abandoned by most international leaders
she had only one prominent visitor
russia's vladimir putin who certainly
knew at the time that the relation
between the two powerful nations would
soon change that's because russia needs
china after the west has distanced
itself from moscow russia might be
optimistic last year trade with china
reached a record 147 billion dollars
it's set to reach 250 billion dollars
soon that's 40 percent more than current
trade volume between russia and the eu
currently russia is china's second
biggest oil supplier providing over 15
percent of its imports the country also
covers five percent of china's demand
for natural gas meanwhile the food trade
has been growing fast in 2019 china
allowed the import of soybeans from
russia last year it added beef to the
import list and just last week wheat
china is also a huge buyer of timber
from russia's far east with imports
worth over 4 billion dollars last year
as for trade in the other direction
china sells machinery mobile phones cars
and consumer products to russia with
exports up 34 last year china is also
russia's largest foreign investor having
issued at least 125 billion dollars
worth of loans for infrastructure
projects that are largely tied to
china's belt and road initiative
as russia counts on china as its new key
trade partner beijing might show some
hesitance though wary of trouble with
its western partners should it run afoul
of sanctions
for more let's cross over to taipei and
dw correspondent so han so how is china
viewing what seems to be quite
remarkable ukrainian resistance against
the russian invasion
china still refused to call it a russian
invasion but rather a conflict between
russia and ukraine it urges the
ukrainian side to assume the
corresponding international
responsibility and does not condemn
russia at all but after the call between
chinese and ukrainian foreign minister
earlier china signaled that it was ready
to play the role of a peacemaker beijing
said that ukraine looks forward to china
playing a role in realizing a ceasefire
at the same time when russia called
china as its friend the related chinese
twitter weibo by russian state media
sputnik was deleted was deleted shortly
afterwards many chinese citizens said
that we are not friends don't pull china
down like this don't want to be friends
with the aggressor and others worry that
such statements would be detrimental to
the safety of chinese people in ukraine
now on the economic front china has
vowed to strengthen ties with russia
what does that look like now that
western sanctions against moscow are
starting to bite
well we have seen chinese economic and
financial support for russia even though
china does not directly support russia's
expansionism to any degree beijing
strongly feels the necessity to maintain
and boost strategic partnership with
moscow china has been supplying
electronics machinery and other
manufactured goods to russia in exchange
for food and energy on the first day of
russia's attack on ukraine china
suddenly announced that it would allow
the import of wheat throughout the
territory of russia which was partly
banned due to contamination problems but
we are not sure if china will further
help russia because it is in a difficult
position and needs to strike a delicate
balance with the chinese government more
than willing to avoid any action that
could easily expose china to further
sanctions
and so speaking of uh possible
partnership now that a number of russian
banks have been kicked off the
international payment system swift are
china and russia going to link both of
the national financial transaction
systems each one has been putting up
despite the fact that russia and china
have strengthened the deduction of local
currency settlement in recent years
russia and china still rely heavily on
swift for cross-border settlement
payments in 2017 commercial bank of
china launched its renminbi clearing
bank business in moscow a number of
russian banks have joined it and russian
chinese gas oil and gold transactions
can be settled in renminbi but even if
the settlement and payment information
of china and russia can be exchanged
within the country by passing swift the
cross-border exchange can only be done
through swift besides in order to
promote the internationalization of
renminbi it is difficult for china to
act independently of swift it is a very
complicated issue and we don't see how
it can ease russia's pressure in the
short term
dw correspondent so songhan in taipei so
thank you
volkswagen and bmw are the most recent
examples the two car makers just
announced they're temporarily halting
production in some plans as key
components are missing russia's invasion
of ukraine and the west's sanctions
against moscow are disrupting supply
chains which are yet to recover from the
coronavirus pandemic
the closure of russian airspace because
of the invasion is set to cause massive
restrictions on international air cargo
and air traffic
cargo flights and passenger aircraft to
asia have to take a different route
lufthansa cargo says that flights from
central europe to japan korea and china
can take up to several hours longer and
can carry up to 20 percent less freight
this will make flights and freight more
expensive
shipping is also feeling the
consequences of the war and the
sanctions against russia
the world's largest container shipping
company maersk suspended most container
deliveries to and from the country
freight traffic with russia is at a
standstill
factories in europe's biggest economy
germany are worried about bottlenecks
especially in raw materials and
intermediate products and possible price
increases german car makers have around
50 suppliers and manufacturing sites in
russia and ukraine it's still too early
to predict what impact the war will have
russia and ukraine are among the largest
exporters of wheat accounting for about
one third of global exports but these
exports are now at risk and this is
hitting poorer countries in africa and
latin america in particular which are
dependent on cheap imports
[Music]
and now to some of the other global
business stories making headlines
apple ford and exxon mobil have joined
the rank of companies who halt business
in russia apple said it would stop the
sale of iphones and other products in
the country ford and exxon will suspend
operations
germany's siemens now says it will also
suspend business in russia
russia's biggest lander spare bank is
exiting the european market as western
sanctions tighten following the russian
war in ukraine the announcement came
just hours after the european central
bank ordered the closure of spare banks
european arm following a run on deposits
home rental company airbnb says it'll
offer free temporary housing for up to
10 100 000 refugees fleeing ukraine
ceo brian jeske said letters to send
letters to leaders of poland romania
germany and hungary offering help to
house
the people at least 300 000 ukrainian
refugees have entered the eu since the
russian invasion began
a firm that tracks cryptocurrency
transactions says more than 33 million
dollars in the digital currency has been
donated to ukraine's government and
non-governmental organizations based in
the country ukraine has received the
donations mostly in the form of bitcoin
and ethereum
after making
an appeal on twitter last week after it
was invaded by russia
and as corporations around the world
review their business activities in
russia big trade gatherings are taking a
stand as well the mobile world congress
in barcelona is the world's biggest
mobile phone show
and it's taking place this week it has
limited russian companies access to the
event
at the russian stand there's little sign
of the company's country of origin even
the name russia has been taped over
apparently at the request of the
congress's organizers
most of the participants here are
software companies like av soft from
moscow they say sanctions are hitting
the wrong targets
of course i repeat business is not
connect with policy at all in modern
world in modern world
so we shouldn't decide about something
on
not connected events together financial
cyber security business
and government so it's different spheres
at all
one company worried about sanctions is
moscow-based true conf it provides
online conference software worldwide
i think is
could be
[Music]
significant for
all
russian companies and so on
after dw's camera was turned off he said
he'd likely have to split the company
into two
one in russia and one in the eu
the russian war against ukraine and
sanctions are overshadowing the mobile
world congress
at a time when participants had hoped to
get back to business as usual after two
years of the pandemic
so what's in store next for the business
world
every industry is going to have some
kind of impact i mean clearly we already
had a geopolitical divide in in the
world and this will further enhance that
the only company from ukraine slated to
participate this year a virtual reality
studio from kiev wasn't able to attend
because of the war
you